it's time for screen junkies boobie
bytes what's going on guys welcome to
movie fights hash tag movie fights live
guess what we're not live we're coming
to you pre-recorded but it's still gonna
have most of the fun that you're used to
and a shout out to hash tag owl nation
this is hashtag person well the owl hoot
hoot this is a very special fight you
guys with the release of Aquaman we're
gonna get pretty wet today that sounded
weird but we're taking a deep dive we're
getting in the water and these are all
aquatic fights let's meet our ocean
dwellers for today first off he is a man
familiar with log flumes and what other
what are their raft ride rides boxis
he's got very exciting fun podcast
called podcast the ride where he talks
all about amusement parks Mike Carlson
welcome to the park I thank you for
having me at the water party I am
excited to be here yes I covered a water
park on podcast the ride we just you
know what thank you hell for letting us
plug because on our patreon exclusive
episode this week we cover Blizzard
Beach the wonderful Orlando Disney World
waterpark and it's great check it out
yeah
next up you know I'm from honest
trailers sju all over the place oh he's
got a well welcome to beard today
Welch joseffer full of water yes get
that bucket after we're done can I just
ask Mike to rank lazy rivers that's
after we're done with the whole thing
yeah yeah maybe maybe later in the show
I don't know if we include resorts where
we include on today's panel the hosts
one of the hosts of everything's coming
up Simpsons on the max fun Network
Simpsons related podcast and she's aced
one of the premiere Simpsons enthusiasts
and super fun lady Julia Prescott thanks
so much for having me oh yeah
pleasure
yeah a lot of people were talking about
you and Mike have a nice little Botanica
a fandom and connection that I was
unaware but it makes sense because I'm I
feel like if I didn't have a sense as a
podcast I would probably try and have a
theme park podcast too so write all the
best friends were mortal enemies but
we'll see at the end of today's fight
well yeah you will be in battle and
kwatak movie fights and deciding the
fate of these Brea
nicely done a real sea change deciding
the fate of these brave combatants be
myself in the damn kam welcome to the
party Dan's dan Merle checking the facts
and how raining movie fights champion
let me ask you this yes do you being the
champion as you check facts does that do
you ever does that ever creep in how do
you keep that like in out of your
purview as far as like checking facts
and deciding the judging I mean I think
that I've been very very clearly recused
myself ow and I feel I have a conflict
of interest otherwise I want everyone to
play to their full potential because a
true champion wants to play the best
he'll you know what sportsmanship
Fairplay Dan Merle thank you so much and
the voice of the people but today she is
voicing her own opinions Danielle
Radford yeah so today I am there are no
polls because this is pre-taped but
please keep the discussion going on
movie fights live y'all come up with
some of the greatest memes and answers I
love going through all of those and I
love the way that you guys all talk to
each other during the show so please
continue to do that throughout the show
and I will be checking that out so
awesome Danielle not me now me later but
you know you can still tweet corgis to
Danielle Radford during the show even
though we're not live okay yes yes
please send me an duh what do you say we
dive in and get this started JT e
dropped that package
ladies and gentlemen
[Music]
Thank You Thor all right so again the
this is four points to take the victory
today three regular round questions and
then the top two performers will
continue on to the speed round where
it's anybody's game you come down 300
and come storm right back in the speed
round here is question number one
besides jaws what's the best movie set
at sea besides jaws best movie set at
sea and question one start with player
one my coffin ahoy
I'd like to choose a movie that tells a
whale of a tale I'm talking about I'm
being completely serious 20,000 Leagues
Under the Sea the 1954 Walt Disney
classic this folks is an exciting movie
a thoughtful movie a movie with a giant
rubber squid battle it is exciting now
that seems silly but it's not it's fun
it's exciting it's what everyone loves
giant practical puppets alright this
movie my goodness it has the sets are
amazing the design the Nautilus is an
iconic ship and let's be honest folks it
has the most important thing any movie
should have grizzled character actors
alcohol-soaked
character actors that drink while
they're acting they look bad but it only
adds to their character it makes it feel
more real it makes this whole situation
seem more dire James Mason Kirk Douglas
and my favorite Peter Lorre I don't talk
on movie fights enough about Peter Lorre
if you don't know about him he sounds
like this he sounds like her in from Ren
and Stimpy he's incredible folks you
can't take your eyes off this weird
little man this is an underappreciated
classic people don't talk about it
enough there's so many theme park rides
based on it some gone some still there
20,000 Leagues Under the Sea it's
amazing
alright 20,000 Leagues joestar I'm gonna
pick another movie then was going to
have a theme park attraction attached to
it but that did not end up happening
much to Disney's not chagrin they
probably don't regret that it didn't
happen but they should have done it they
lost out creatively I'm talking to
Atlantis the lost Empire this is a this
little movie a little under loved
underrated movie from Disney where they
they tried to get out of the musical
business and tried to step into the
world of PG animation tried to bring in
some of those teen boys for for for an
adventure that I'll describe is one part
Stargate one part good version of Avatar
but underwater it's a really great movie
it's super fun cast Michael J Fox great
voice actor sort of leads the whole
thing it's a jules verne inspired tale
because you can't really do underwater
without repping the verne but more than
that instead of a normal Disney House
style they actually adapted the visual
style of Hellboy creator Mike Magnolia
which i think was a really cool visually
sort of brave move from Disney instead
of just doing a generalized like how
will this end up looking in Disney
infinity someday giving it its own like
really cool style Atlantis in this movie
is really creative and inventive it has
its own language the action scenes are
great there's a really cool giant
robotic squid fight it's a fun movie
alright Atlantis lost Empire
Julia Prescott I'm so excited to talk
about my entry into this question today
I'm of course here to talk about Muppet
Treasure Island now this is the second
entry into what I will call the Muppets
in the mid 90s the mid to late 90s they
were back baby we all remember the you
know three 70s and 80s Muppet movies
that sort of establish them in the
feature film category
this is them they're newer they've got
new characters they've got fresh music
Hans Zimmer did the soundtrack I'm sorry
the score same [ __ ] to Muffet Treasure
Island we've got Tim Curry in there Tim
Curry Peak curry this is when he was you
know trying to be more of a
family-friendly Tim Curry around this
time is when he also co-starred in home
loan two lost in New York as we all
recall it makes you feel good let me be
real the ocean is scary right you know a
lot of the movies that we say about the
ocean
you know make it seem like a scary place
jaws is in the question that being like
the leading example but the ocean is
most of the planet Earth so we shouldn't
be scared of it we should be approaching
it with comedies with feel-good family
entertainment and you really don't get
better than the Muppets
I think I've said everything that I want
to about this topic back to you maybe
say a little more because it's time to
fight it out okay you watch these other
two movies and they're fine movies but
do any of the actors in those movies
seem drunk no this is a movie where you
can feel the reality of being underwater
at sea which is bleak and desolate these
people they didn't the actors didn't go
and have a three-martini lunch in a
Burbank I just want to clarify you're
saying that the actors are drunk while
they're acting in the movie they're not
just alcoholics outside of the set I'm
saying all of that all of that all the
above the whole thing above I know
saying that this gives this a reality
this gives us an edge over these other
two movies that's what I'm saying I will
say that you only like 20,000 weeks on
at sea because of the theme park
connection it's certainly a big part of
it I'm not gonna deny that well I said
the words exciting several times in
succession of this movie but I feel like
the only exciting part is the squid part
which is all of how many minutes on
screen five minutes or so that is a
generous five I think it's actually two
minutes maybe it is two minutes I don't
know exactly Tube video yeah this is I
find thoughtfulness exciting okay and
that's what this movie is it's
thoughtful so when I say exciting I
don't necessarily mean just like whiz
Pal bang punching I mean thoughtful in
its in its things that it has to say
about America in the world what was your
favorite part of 20,000 Leagues Under
the Sea that was non squid related quote
a quote from the film well a whale of a
tale certainly is my favorite one of my
favorite parts when Kirk Douglas gets to
sing that fun song on a ship that's
pretty great that's a good chant that's
a pretty great that's a good you know
the only thing I can really counter the
they were drunk on set with is the the
power of a voice a voice over actor
being
to choose whether or not to wear pants
they get to perform very comfortably
they might be sober but they're also
very comfortable whether they're in
sweats oh they're just in their pajamas
or a robe you know Michael J Fox got to
just come into this thing maybe have a
drink after but definitely was
comfortable in his performance if not
completely hammered so are you are you
saying that their record like they're
recording these from home just wearing
sweat pants or whatever or they're going
into work just where I'm at right you
know wearing whatever why not drive it
into Disney Burbank wearing a bathrobe
okay box Michael J Fox pulls that kind
of weight I think I think he went back
in time before I would say that um my
purchase Ryland has a similar kind of
thing for the voiceover actors for the
Muppets in the film that they have that
sort of ease I want to say a couple more
things about this movie 91% of Google
users love to this movie GU --gel users
are what the mate what makes the world
go round
it's a remake remakes are great
everybody loves a remake because it's a
fresh take on a beloved franchise as I
mentioned Hans Zimmer did the score for
it which makes it very legit and I also
read on the Wikipedia page that the end
credits song love power by ziggy marly
featured Muppets with dreads and who can
argue say that is just like you know
we're thinking about that Kermit Kokomo
video we're thinking about you know how
we ourselves maybe want dreads don't I
think but I want to make sure that we
know Kokomo is not in Muppets Treasure
Island that is this is so you're right
trying to draw a comparison with a great
music video I think we just need to make
sure the same production company so you
would say that it is sort of in its own
Marvel Universe I wouldn't say that
bow is a part of my argument for
incredibles to just cuz it opened in
front of it but that was still good I
mean that that's a different argument
for a different day I would say that
there are no other see comedies in this
area except for maybe down periscope or
McHale's Navy which were not too great
examples of this not since splash have
we seen the ocean picked it in such a
light harder there are some good laughs
in Atlantis the lost Empire there is a
with know definitely whether there is a
stereotypical French bomber who is
hilarious he's obsessed with blowing
things up and he's very stereotypically
from another country he's super fun has
some great laps those are the only ones
coming to mind so maybe I can't go to
toe with you comedy wise but again giant
mechanical squid that's a great sequence
this is Disney starting to merge sort of
CG with their hand-drawn animation for
the first time more than that just when
was the last time Disney did something
brave great let's shift it here's here
we'll move to final Foss and BAM
questions answered nicely done Prescott
when they do something brave they did
path let's go into final thoughts and I
want to hear we've heard a lot about
what makes it fun what makes your movie
just like oh just a super good time I
want to hear what makes it a good film
as well and I guess some of your choices
start with Mike well I want to quickly
just say that these other two movies are
not memorable they've not lasted in the
popular culture like elements of 20,000
Leagues people know the Nautilus people
know the giant squid no one I had to
Google like who was even in Atlantis I
could not remember the plot of Muppets
Treasure Island which I couldn't Island
which is because it made me forget the
plot of Treasure Island the famous one
but 20,000 Leagues is about something
Captain Nemo has bloodlust he wants to
prevent the world from going to war but
while he's trying to prevent the world
he makes it worse he makes the bat he
makes fighting happen he makes bloodshed
happen and that is a point about the
American governor
military-industrial complex and I think
this movie is actually saying something
whereas these other two movies are just
like fluff all right Thank You Mike
Carlson Joestar you know a big part of
Atlantis the lost Empire revolves around
you know the argument of preserving
something and letting it sort of live on
its own to thrive or exploiting it
specifically exploiting the powers
within to to sell them to the Kaiser of
Germany at the dawn of World War one so
that's kind of a military-industrial
complex thing I think Atlantis has a
really good blend
they blend action and also just sort of
like thoughtful adventure if that makes
any sense really really well there's a
couple of big action scenes but it
doesn't rely on them it's really a very
like character and moral driven movie
the designs are really great Milo and
the princess it's probably one of the
best princesses in Disney she's very
very underrated I think she's great
she has a very cool design they're very
cool performances they also have a lot
of chemistry together and you know as
far as animated characters to have a
crush on and go you can't you can't do
you know that's pretty good duo to have
a crush on they're very good-looking
animated characters all right Joe star
crushing on those animated characters
Julia Prescott okay so I just want to
say up top that there's no such thing as
chemistry in an animated film because
that is forced through the storyboard
artists and just want to get that out of
the gate so I just want to say about
Muppet Treasure Island everybody loves
them up at movi because they mix
family-friendly sort of environment and
a feel with irreverent humor they play
to the adults as much as they play to
the kids I would say that this is
entirely memorable again as I mentioned
it is during their mental late 90s
resurgence of Muppet movies and the
music is very catchy and I feel like it
did humanize Tim Curry quite a bit
especially after I'm his take as the
lead in it during the 90s so this was a
good turn for him that kind of got him
nestled into that area I would say that
Muppet Treasure Island this came out in
predated Titanic who held the door for
who you got it's who held the door for
who and wanna say that you know this
movie also featured a young ingenue by
the name of Kevin Clash who later went
on to Elmo Fame he did mostly he's been
since praised this movie they you know
the filmmakers Frank Oz he was like I
can't do I'm only one man I can't do all
of the typical characters that I do in a
Muppet movie so in order to make the
film better so that he was instructing
himself too thin he brought on Kevin
Clash who did some of Miss Piggy and you
know some of the other Frank Oz
characters and I think it made it better
in the end again we didn't know what we
didn't know back then but I think that
it did make it for a better movie
alright pre disgrace yeah pre disgrace
is the area I want to live in time Oh
should we all live in the blessed area
pre disgrace you know notice Creek yeah
pre disgrace indicators would be
disgraced coming Titanic factually what
do you got for us
Oh looking at so many different things
oh yeah man Kevin Clash had been
associated with the Muppets for a while
he'd been on he'd been doing Elmo he'd
been on Sesame Street a little bit but
you know okay that's a different camp
than Muppets proper I think that's
debatable but let's I don't want to get
bogged down in Muppet bore yeah
soundcheck first to score it's weird
it's sort of like a square rectangle
question which is it scores the the
instrumental music that's written
directly for a film right and it is part
of the soundtrack but the soundtrack is
not the score so I think it's not
necessarily the same thing as it's that
there are slight differences and Muppet
Treasure Island Mike was correct Muppet
Treasure Island does not have Kokomo
however there is a muppet version of
Kokomo and a music video that was
released in 1988 as part of the muppet
beats Party album so is John Stamos also
in that me no he's not
unless he is showing the puppeteering
for one of the Fozzie Bear or one of the
there's also may possibly on the same
album might be in a different one Jimmy
Buffett teams up with Kermit
to sing Caribbean amphibian Wow
yeah I want to let everyone know we
already knew Dan any info on whether or
not James Mason and Peter Lorre were
actually in in 12-step programs or
alcohol well I don't want to get sued by
the estates of either all right I'm
gonna definitively work as a fact
checker and tell you whether or not that
is true because I don't have money for a
lawyer how all right
noted and I hear you on that yeah only a
lawyer on sju I'm sorry all right Daniel
Radford why don't we start off with your
thoughts on this battle oh these are all
fantastic arguments but when it came to
just getting them knocked up and
knocking him down one person that came
to win today and that is Julia Prescott
just every argument she was sniping so
Julia wins this round for me easily yeah
I you know I'm tending to agree like I
feel just as far as bullet points there
as far as like the number of things that
she liked from the film and as far as oh
just wouldíve parries and retorts julia
was really on point Mike had a lot of
great stuff but it was it was a lot of
fun stuff around the film that less
posited how great the film was and more
just like oh look at this cool lore
surrounding this film and I feel like
Joe painted a great case for me wanting
to like revisit this kind of forgotten
Disney film but Julie I feel knocked out
of the park so I'm going to Juliet Julia
takes the first point finally I just
wanna like I think it would be remiss of
me not to note there are so many choices
from the golden era of Hollywood of
seafaring movies I just wrote down a few
that came to me a night to remember the
first Titanic movie lifeboat the actual
Titanic Captain Blood the Caine Mutiny
mutiny on the bounty
sash their commanders my I love master
master
we love we love the love we love that we
love and what about our Kurt Russell and
Goldie Hawn and overboard I know but
they're not really on the angle ah yeah
there's some landlubbing I considered
that in my argument right on but good
stuff and yeah I by the way Jim Jimmy
Buffett and Kermit the Frog do edit on
Caribbean amphibian and the TV special
Elmo Palooza part of me I'm sorry
he showed me Kermit and dreads and I
will never be the same oh my god used to
play that on the Disney Channel as
interstitials for years mm-hmm I mean is
that like just like weirdly awful
appropriate marlis there it's a whole
thing yeah definitely the guy in your
psych 101 class and that you just don't
want to follow into a parking lot he's
going through a really cool phase in
college okay
you know what it's 100 Julia Joe Mike
looking to get on the board Lester I'm
on here I love it here we go
keep those water puns coming question
number two who is the greatest sea
captain in any movie question number two
we'll start with player number two mr.
Joestar how when I think of this
question I think of two things how can i
it's not just who's who's the best sea
captain but it's also how can I best
disappoint Dan today the best way I can
think of to disappoint Dan is to
completely with this round on an attempt
to argue Quint from Jaws look there are
a lot of important things to consider
when considering what makes the best sea
captain it's not necessarily does he
live because the sea is a dangerous
place as we've already established in
this fight but it's a it's about are you
willing to just get in there and look
the sea in the face and just tell it to
eat your butt because you don't care
about body end up telling the
just eat your but there's also a salt
factor how how salty is your sea captain
and I defy these two to find a saltier
dog than a man who starts a conversation
with a group of people by just clawed
his fingers down a chalkboard and just
reminded them that he doesn't need to
introduce himself because damn it he's
Quint y'all know him y'all know what he
do again it's this is a guy who has not
necessarily thrived in the ocean but he
just keeps surviving he keeps cheating
death because the ocean may or may not
be in fact scared of him
Quint thank you for that and I love how
salty is your sea captain that could be
like the catchphrase for a rum Thank You
Joestar Quint from Jaws Julia all right
so I'm arguing captain Phillips of
course the titular character from the
Tom Hanks film captain Phelps which I
might add was nominated for a great deal
of Oscars the year that it came out yes
may I will agree that Quint is a very
salty sea captain but I feel like we've
got the salty sea captain down we need
something a little bit more optimistic I
think what appeals to the larger
audience of people that come to you know
see war quor'toth movies I'm just gonna
invent that genre now is that we want to
put ourselves into the narrative we want
to feel like we could save a ship of
crew and and a commercial you know a
loading ship and we could beat Tom Hanks
in this and I feel like he is the
everyman I also feel like he's all of
our dads and we love our dads so that's
what i'm voting for captain phillips is
the best sea captain all right I know I
often feel like I want to save a
commercial loading ship Mike Carlson all
right I like to choose my sea captain's
like America likes to choose the
president what sea captain would I have
a beer with who would I want to have
and a bar that's why my answers of
course captain Ron the greatest sea
captain of all time Kurt Russell look at
him he's glorious he has those look he
braids in his hair I mean he is
wonderful
this is captain fun dad folks this is a
guy who will buy you beer whether you're
underage whether you're overage it
doesn't matter he's buying you beer
you're sitting out on a boat with him
he's got a little transistor radio he's
playing Caribbean amphibian by Jimmy
Buffett and Kermit the Frog on it it is
a cool vibe you're having a great time
it is look that we can get captains that
are good at driving a ship whatever you
call it drive your ship is that what you
called boat piloting a ship whatever it
doesn't even matter let's stay in the
dock let's crack open a six-pack let's
listen to some fun stuff on the radio
captain Ron the greatest sea captain of
all time all right fight it out captains
I prefer a captain who won't drink
something unless it's from a flask I
mean I want to be saved by a sea captain
I don't know about you guys I mean I
don't feel like captain Ron can save us
when he can't even get a bank loan you
know what I mean sometimes you're having
a problem a row with your old lady and
he can save you by having a couple beers
with you and telling you how life is
what he's gone through that can save a
man's life you know what life is because
he's just out to sea he's got the Sun
baking into his brain he doesn't know
but there's so much more wise in a lot
of ways the sea is more real life than
land I feel like I feel like Ron is the
guy that flunked out of ship captains
school he absolutely did that's great
quit didn't even bother going to sea
captain school and sea captain school
was like I get it you know we're sort of
talking about B you want to talk about
having a row with your old lady Quint
has the all-time greatest hey hey Bros
let's just sit down and solve these old
lady rows like that that's the ultimate
let's sit down with the guys and hash
out some [ __ ] see say that Captain Ron
is an easy choice but captain Phillips
is the thinking man's choice right
because it's very easy
very cool with a 10 and a puka-shell
necklace and braids but it is very hard
than you think it is very hard to look
badass in a polo shirt that is stained
and he's got weird LensCrafters on and
he manages to make it work first of all
it's very easy to drive a boat let's get
that out of the way right here so
captain Phillips isn't whether he looks
cool which I disagree nothing is cooler
than Kurt Russell we're all having Kurt
Russell fevery Santa Claus but we forget
he was Captain Ron first he was a
shirtless man he was the original
Captain Jack Sparrow the better Captain
Jack Sparrow you honestly think that
Captain Ron could pull a move where he
witnesses one of the Somali pirates does
not have shoes and then he very
inconspicuous ly messages the rest of
his crew who they do not know he's still
on the goddamn ship and he tells them
break glass and scatter it around so
that this Somali pirate can get bloody
so that you can change the dynamic quit
would drown those pirates and Chum I
here just put a nice old-fashioned ocean
strangle where he and my daddy's gonna
win captain Ron though you pull out a
bag and he goes you guys get high and
they get high everyone gets high and
they would get a high with him and the
crisis would have been averted no high
jinks would have had to go on down I
want to refresh the panel's memory do
you remember soccer practice
waiting for your parents to pick you up
and it doesn't matter if it's five
minutes or five hours it feels [ __ ]
crushing like you've been forgotten
mm-hmm captain Ron would not be bothered
to pick us up from soccer practice I
just want to let you guys know that you
guys are having a weird daddy fight so
weird daddy
push this a little further Quinn is the
sexy granddaddy just let's just let's
just break through the mold and just go
that dirty crab just mr. Q captain Q
right here again this guy this guy went
he's not a poser like Captain Ron
if the moment came or captain Ron had to
go down with the ship or get eaten by a
shark captain Ron would just like throw
puka shells at the shark and run for his
life captain Quint was like okay bring
it I argue the cap that Quint was not
killed by that shark he is alive he
survived it there's no way a mere shark
could kill Quint that seems like a silly
thing to argue well quit as you said
look the sea in the face and said I
believe eat my butt yes yes okay but I
just wanted to make I wanted to be sure
captain Phillips looked a Somali pirate
in the face and his crew and basically
said eat my butt and I would say that a
face to face versus face to ocean
encounter is much more difficult my good
captain wrong one of different ladies
and probably men as well he probably is
headers but even at sea plenty of times
Luud right right right right but that
wasn't a dangerous harrowing experience
don't know some of the people he was
hooking up with it was probably a
dangerous situation not that he cared
about it then you know what let's shift
gears into our final thoughts here Joe
start us off with your quintessential
final thoughts on Quint you know I think
Quint checks a lot of boxes here you
know just because of how long he was at
sea with the armed forces and otherwise
I think he's probably also a very
sexually feel fluid gentleman just as
much as captain Ron again just in terms
of pure saltiness and grittiness you
know this is a man who's not even
wearing real clothes
those are barnacles that have just sort
of shaped themselves and into a work
certain hat this guy is a part of the
sea he was born in the sea he was raised
by the sea and to the sea he returned
did Quint he is the best at singing
drunk sea shanties he would never sing a
song that is about anything not ocean
related he takes a bunch of landlubbers
and
turns them into turns them into real
sailors in like a day that's pretty
impressive
and then when the sea comes to take him
home he doesn't hesitate
he just gets eaten by it Quint Thank You
Joestar Julia
Prescott thank you I would say a measure
of a true hero is someone who does not
step into a situation anticipating
heroism to be called upon them he was a
merchant mariner you guys by the way
this is based on a true story so I would
say that that is already winning my
notes okay he just thought that he was
going into another basic job his life on
the high seas is very boring and that's
the way he likes it
he never thought that he would have to
face off with terrorists like the Somali
pirates but he did and he succeeded and
lest we forget one of the best lines
that has ever emerged from cinema
history I'm the captain now we all said
it and we'll all say it again it was the
my wife of that year it also took a cab
driver to start him and he went to the
Oscars and he had a great time all right
Thank You Julia
Mike folks quint is a fun character but
let's be honest you're hanging out with
Quint he's gonna have post-traumatic
stress and you'll find him strangling
you in the middle of the night that is
what's going to happen
captain Phillips to hang out with this
is a guy who's uptight he probably has
paperwork to fill out it gets very
tedious he's a by-the-book kind of a guy
he's like I'll let you drink beer on the
deck he's not gonna let you hang off the
anchor like fun he's not gonna let you
do some crazy dives she doesn't like
that he's uptight captain Ron first of
all I want to remind everyone easy to
drive a boat it doesn't matter
these guys can drive a boat all day long
do it I've never done and I'm sure I can
do it it's not hard so that part is
taken care of he's on that he's equal
with these these two choices all right
but this C is a lonely place the C can
get very cold and you can forget but you
need a person there with you that is fun
and is entertaining and this is captain
ROM this is his MO baby captain Ron the
best sea captain of all time all right
time there you have it
Wow three pretty different captain's den
Merle where are we on fact captain
Phillips was nominated for six Oscars
ironically no nomination for Tom Hanks
yeah no Quinn captain Phillips he's more
about getting a career Oscar nom yes and
with that the word I did a search of the
the scripts from all of the films the
word but does not appear in any of the
mentioned films so I told the sea to eat
them but it did not happen on screen
spiritually I will say the jell-o made a
bit of a miscalculation because of my
jobs to be the fact checker and you're
talking about Quint then get ready for
some quints cuz here we go oh yeah buddy
he doesn't say you all know me you know
what I do it's y'all know me you know
how I earn a living
Joe said that he wouldn't want to be
with the guy who didn't drink anything
out of a flask quit famously drinks beer
out of a can and he drinks liquor from a
cup but drinks nothing from a flask and
the movie Jaws Quint was in the Navy
which you could arguably count as sea
captain school and Matt you said he took
a couple of landlubbers on the board and
turned him shipshape in a couple of days
Matt Hooper was not a landlubber as a
matter of fact he was a member of the
oceanographic institute with a boat of
his own so that is also inaccurate
therefore I have to disqualify Joe in
facts alone Wow gotcha yeah and as your
set as you were rattling off that list
and you have your jaws cell phone case
sticking out of your pocket so it's like
I am here from the jaws official Society
I see her chocha on to do what you got
to get ready if you know that I'm
checking the facts you got to bring the
family already played he showed his
cards by saying he was gonna disappoint
Dan let's let's keep your voyage going
go ahead and give us your thoughts on
this so obviously it was between Mike
and Julia for me and I Julia had me
going for for most of the fight I've got
to be honest but I thought Mike fought
back very well against the slams on
captain Ron and then I really felt that
his closing argument encapsulated why
his was the best choice all around so I
I my vote would go to Mike and would go
to captain Ron boom one one for captain
Ron
Julia I felt like when you did I mean
stain your closing argument to include
I'm the captain now that was someone
taking your captain's mantle from him
like that doesn't help that's like for
the move but that stoked the flame for
him to rise up like a phoenix from the
ashes and become the hero that he was
always meant to be if he didn't have
that hound is over I know but I
appreciate that
yeah reshape those thoughts and Mike I
thought you made a great argument for a
cool uncle but the question was great a
sea captain and you know Dan you like
yeah yeah you you really you know the
specificity and and the the the accuracy
of some of his statements are called
into question but you know the flask the
some of the some of the verbage that
doesn't remove from from my mind that
like he laid out some powerful arguments
for Quint just being a captain who has a
history a captain who gave himself to
the sea when the time came that was
really that really spoke to me and the
question here is great a sea captain
I felt like Mike painted a picture I'm a
fun captain I felt Julia paint a picture
of a workman like captain but for me I
mean despite those factual inaccuracies
as as far as some of the specifics like
the
meet of the argument was still there
from what I heard from Joe so a couple
of the side dishes change but the meat
of the arguments still won me over for
kappa for captain Quint Danielle where
you stand
you know I absolutely have to agree with
you I think that I joe's arguments were
laid out very well again there were some
of those inaccuracies but he did still
even if one of them was no she ologist
which is a profession we have all
learned today even though you think he's
still we know there was still one
landlubber on there that he was able to
teach and I think Joe's argument stand
so if I go with Joe also um I did make
the mistake of looking up shark and eat
my butt and it turns out there is an
episode of a show and IMDB called eat my
butt shark so Joe managed to accomplish
what he set out to do piss off Dan and
get the fine name yes he then he did not
give himself too he was kicking and
screaming he was literally grabbing at
every he did not valiantly give himself
to the scene that hurt is a gross
mischaracterization one you over with
this argument if that was a rancid fish
meat of an hour
that's not accurate to the film you
coming with quit but not like that Joe
you did but I have no respect you didn't
just managed to piss off Dan you
offended Dan sacred beliefs don't ever
change I love it I love it so Joestar
you get the point I won't play good sir
Wow happened yes it did yes it did and
I'll rancid fish meet another club
that's a classic I like how salty is our
sea captain and rancid fish meat um so
the score stands Julia 1 Joe 1 Mike
looking to get on the board let's go to
question number 3 here we go what movie
would most be improved by adding Jason
Momoa as Aquaman to the cast so we can
we can stay in the sea we can get out of
the sea we can yeah wherever we can go
up in the air for all we know all right
what movie most improved by adding Jason
Momoa as Aquaman to the cast and let's
start with player number 3 Julia
Prescott my answer for this question is
of course the shape of water what was
last year's big Oscar hit from Guillermo
del Toro
I loved the shape of water but I had one
question that was lingering after it um
how does the fish feel about this
relationship we don't really know it
doesn't really pass if there were a
Bechtel test for just aquatic creatures
it doesn't really pass I feel like it's
a one-way street and he could be
exclaiming I don't like this for all we
know
we don't know so my suggestion is adding
Jason Momoa in there maybe to give the
fish character a little bit more of a
backstory it could be his cool cousin or
it's cool gonna be like yo what's up
like he tells me you know great things
about you
you know like and welcome to the family
you know how like when you're dating
somebody early on you meet the people in
their circle and it colors your vision
of them and you understand them a little
bit more that could give a little bit
more of that gravity that I feel was so
severely lacking from their romantic
courtship so that is my answer
gray Bechdel test for sea creatures Mike
Carlson the world is in crisis hell
global warming is threatening us all and
no one is listening and what how are we
going to do anything about it now I'm
one man did try to do that he's released
a sequel but he tried like about 10 ish
years ago to make a movie that would
warn us to tell us this is Al Gore and
I'm talking about the movie An
Inconvenient Truth why didn't people
listen to this movie I would argue
because it didn't have a bro E character
in it to relate to the common man Al
Gore's very stuffy but the story of
someone you don't listen to if Aquaman
Jason Momoa Aquaman was in Inconvenient
Truth he would have warned us and we
would have listened I guarantee it this
would have changed the course of mankind
there's still time there's still time to
make an inconvenient truth whatever it
is 3 with Aquaman in it and he will
adequately warn us and we will all of a
sudden go off carbon we will do all we
know coal no oil only green energy once
Jason Momoa as Aquaman tells us to all
right Mike Carlson positing an
inconvenient trilogy Joestar this is a
movie a lot of people like but I just
want to give it a little bit of extra
oomph make it a little more interesting
make it a little more exciting
I want to replace Scarlett Johansson
with Jason Momoa as Aquaman in lost in
translation
you know just cut her out right there
and just put Momoa look look it's a it's
a great movie it's well done but at its
core the concept of a grumpy aging actor
who is out of the country and away from
his wife getting horny for Scarlett
Johansson is not like that interesting
or an outfield thing but replace her
with Jason Momoa and an aging grumpy
Bill Murray just lusting after this
giant haka dancing Hawaiian man who
never wears shoes and I'd used Jason
Momoa and aqua Manor because it's just
Jason Momoa in a costume holding a
trident like there's no deep character
acting going on what you see is what you
get
I think this improves the karaoke scene
I think it makes the whisper scene it
gives the whisper scene a lot more just
levels and I just think it's more
interesting than a than a very glum
Scarlett Johansson walking around Japan
it's just you get this guy who's like
whoa bro yeah this is great
Bill Murray kiss my face like I think
that that is a much more interesting
movie all right fight it out y'all these
are too absurd examples an answer to
this question I just want to say out of
the gate and Joe I will say that your
argument is flimsy because I think that
you're arguing more for Jason Momoa
regular style instead of Jason Momoa as
Aquaman he's still Aquaman like he still
has superpowers like he'll still veiled
like he'll wrap his big beefy arms
around Bill Murray and they'll jump very
high to go to like a different bar
that's maybe at the penthouse of another
building in Tokyo
cool stuff like that and then Bill
Murray can very just sort of like just
undercut with deadpan reactions to this
craziness I think that you also lost
your argument when you didn't name which
song they would sing at karaoke when it
is obviously across the sea by Weezer
could be Kokomo all great options yeah
look I have a lot of things to say about
this lost in translation but real quick
about the shape of water first of all we
don't know that bro Aquaman is an ally
so
he is not the most woke character
necessarily to tell us about consent we
don't know how he feels about me - who
knows I'm not just saying this is not a
slam dunk that this movie is all of a
sudden gonna be less problematic by
adding bro Aquaman to it you know I
would say that just giving the fish
character an additional voice box to
provide more of a backstory to how we
understand this fish character beyond
being a specimen which was the central
argument of the film that we are not to
objectify OC just games voice or is this
could this be a love triangle I mean
let's take it to a table Draft and like
figure it out punch it up - Courtney by
the way these are too horny suggestion
loops
movie with Jason Momoa without making it
horny I just think you know Bill Murray
you know sort of shooting the the
whiskey commercial but Jason Momoa now
comes with him and he's just in a corner
just just being like haha
bro that was great take like Aquaman
there's not gonna be like they can't go
underwater now he's not Bill Murray
can't breathe underwater we can't water
it's a lot of Aquaman honey are you
Fenian truth well it's gonna be better
when Jason Momoa is giving you a mission
statistics atcha is Aquaman gonna be
tooling around with Al Gore at all of
course he's gonna be tooling they're
gonna be in fun Al Gore is going to be
in a boat above water Aquaman is gonna
pop out and go you've got to save the
environment bro
and then he drives back into the water
and we're gonna go man I like that guy
and I like his message I disagree I
think it will discredit the message of
the film and I think I think that I
think Jason Momoa in an inconvenient
truth what three cuz they made two
already is like that one sketch from SNL
that you can't even be bothered like on
the Sunday morning can't be bothered to
click on and your Twitter feed you know
when they do just like the the gift
version of it and you're like I don't
even what is this it's so easy
low-hanging fruit kind of jokes and I
also feel like if we wanted to entice
you know a broader audience to actually
watch Inconvenient Truth we would just
replace alga
Al Gore entirely and maybe put in
somebody fun like I don't know Neil
Patrick Harris where he does close magic
we does close-up magic to tell us about
the inconvenient truths that are to come
now to sort of echo this SNL comparison
my concern about this shape of water
change is that it's going to be more
like that whose line game where you have
like the interpreter and like that's
going to be the whole just stands in a
corner character and he's like shape of
water monster says this and you know I
think that just halts the movie really
kills your pace every time that Momoa
has to step in and be like he says you
look very nice today that kills the pace
a movie besides like the four different
like B story so we have to follow
through all the other side Ken now you
go my god already Momoa Aquaman he's not
he's not the character actor of the
shape of water cast let's be honest all
right Julia let's move to final thoughts
please lead it off I mean as I mentioned
the shape of water got a lot of Oscar
attention you know I think for a good
reason I think that people were horny
for fishes in a way that we've never
seen it's you know time is now and to be
horny for that fish and I feel like um
you know there is no one hornier than
Jason Momoa in that position you know we
were first introduced to him through
Game of Thrones and we all got horned up
for him on land and now we are horned up
for him in the water and I feel like you
matched that with Guillermo del Toro who
is a visionary so it feels like we're
we're all feeling a little bit smarter
watching but also we are super horned up
and I think that both are equally
important to live a full life well right
Julia really leaning into the horned up
angle Mike alright I want you to think
about this this is Inconvenient Truth
this is again this is a movie that we're
trying to make better and then save the
world
nothing was relatable but as we were
talking about Aquaman can talk to sea
life imagine a scene where Aquaman
Aquaman swims up to a whale and by the
way where's my camera
can I get a can I get a specific camera
like cover this camera right here can I
can we switch over hearing it there we
go oh that's
I need to be me Michael there's no
single of me we lost a lot right fine
I'll do it tonight I go Sam that'll do
it to the Tyco point my camera and most
compelling part of this second they
don't know it that's fine I'll do this
I'll do just do it here okay after the
whole standing yes or no I could do that
okay Mike I'm gonna give you your this
is unprecedented there you go all right
oh yeah we're on a single on me okay
yeah so imagine all right he swims into
the water he's swimming into the water
and a whale is making a cry it's sad
okay goes up to the whale and he puts he
cups his hand to the ear and he goes
uh-huh
what's that that's right oh oh no and he
looks over and he goes she's dying bro
hey you [ __ ] okay let's do it one more
time take it back right here the line is
out obviously in post and I'll have a
perfect version she's dying bro just
like our planet No
and that's the last thing of the movie
is that important and MC Hammer does do
the eggheads Inconvenient Truth rap and
now that movie is so much more memorable
the planet is saved
we're in 2018 it's a whole different
ballgame a vote for me everyone has a
vote for the planet all right thank you
Mike
Joestar you know I don't think I don't
think Inconvenient Truth needs saving I
think Al Gore's a very charismatic
gentleman as you can see on his
appearances on South Park and even SNL
stuff like that yeah he's he's a good
sport he can be a very funny guy I think
I think the idea that he is the stick in
the mud that would mean Jason Momoa is a
part of you know the right-wing media
swinging at them when when he was
running for president I think it is it
is just stuck sadly he's been branded as
such but I don't think it's true the
problem with this happening in shape of
water is
I think having this charisma powered
hunk of man now sort of turn you know in
the romantic comedy like the guy who
she's currently with but you're like why
aren't you just with Tom Hanks already
like you're turning your you're turning
the shape of water monster into that
bland guy that like isn't very good with
her kid just people just want her to be
with with Jason Momoa and they're gonna
root against her having sex with that
fish this is the second time today that
I've made Dan disappointed in with me by
referring to this movie over and over
again as the sex of the fish movie dan
I'm gonna make all of this up to you I
swear to God however I think you're
taking your doing an impossible task and
you're taking what is already a beloved
movie and lost in translation and is
cranking it up to 11 I'm not interested
in watching Scarlett Johansson walk
around and go oh different culture but
Jason Momoa walking around and just
being as Aquaman walking around and not
just being like that's interesting thank
you so much oh is this for me
Momoa walk around and be like that's
total [ __ ] bro I can just be like really
excited and really actively celebratory
towards this and a movie where an aging
Bill Murray falls in love with Jason
Momoa is not something that we've ever
seen before and I do think it would
improve the original Lawson translation
plus at the in the whisper Bill Murray
would whisper in his ear and then Jason
Momoa would make a dolphin sound and
Bill Murray's ear that's cute time all
right Wow let's find out which of these
dumb water Dan facts may be the most
important fight we've ever had the
question yes sir they asked the question
asked was what movie would be most
improved by adding Jason Momoa as
Aquaman to the cast okay
then that helps me make up my final
that's what I thought I started to make
sure that I wasn't making my decision
based on and of course a false
assumption of the question being asked I
have no facts but I do have an opinion
if you would like to hear it all right
sure please I think that Julia and Joe
both pitched very potentially
entertaining alternate versions of their
films but I think they both acknowledge
that these are good films that they were
they received attention and recognition
whereas I think where mike has the edge
for me is it is true it does seem like
even though the inconvenient truth was a
very revered fella when people do like
Al Gore they do have to keep making them
people didn't listen to the movie and I
think that he pitched a great way to
improve that film by giving it a
relatable element so that's that's my
that's how I came to my decision based
on the question being asked thank you
Dan yeah I will say I man I don't see
how Momoa and in Lawson translation
would improve it I think it would just
make it like a maybe super weird and fun
but the movies I don't I liked the movie
I liked Sofia Coppola work and III
didn't think you know Scarlett Johansson
did not bother me it just seemed to
bothered you so it really came down to
Julia and Mike for me and I mean Julia
it started to veer a little bit like I
it made sense as far as oh yeah they can
communicate he can hear his thoughts but
like you know the shape of water
monsters cloaca opened so there's
obviously consensually wouldn't open the
cloaca you know I always say that there
is a power dynamic that he felt too
intimidated by this was that woman
giving him the eggs yeah yeah but you
know what I really saw eye to eye with
Dan's reasoning there and like I was
saying this ain't like that would be
maybe just a note we need to get this
message out there and people acting on
it because the the world is no one else
and smoke yeah well twelve years I think
so right 10 to 12 is what they said to
really see some bad things start to
happen but I was gonna get that green
new deal through so yeah so I'm going
Mike Carlson as well and Mike you take
the point Danielle thoughts otherwise I
would have also went with what would
both of your assessments and
um I I do a guy agreed with Joe that
essentially what would have happened is
his poor fish man would have turned into
the Baxter of his movie because even
when you pitched I was with you when you
said Cyrano but then it's like well then
but you know that Cyrano winds up
getting the girl hmm
and then the silencer no is a classic it
is a class listen I'm horned up either
way as I mentioned and that's all that
matters it does bring a full life and
yeah as much as I want to watch and I
really really do want to watch Bill
Murray and Jason Momoa fall in love we
really need him under the sea helping
helping us 20 years ago and whenever
that movie came out oh hell yeah
so it might gets the point by the way
Julia and Joe your answers just
delighted the heck out of me so we are
tied up and let's go to the tiebreaker
it's a great moment in sports reports so
sports thank you sir nobody's gone Marco
all right thank you
there we go so this works the same way
the speed round is gonna work I'm gonna
accept the speed round we'll have to
this is for all three of you I will ask
the question call out your answer then
we'll go will allow you to elaborate in
the order in which we heard your answers
you'll each get 20 seconds then we'll go
back around you'll each get 10 seconds
okay you guys ready for this
yeah let's do that what movie character
would make the best submarine captain
what a movie character would make the
best submarine captain Paddington Bear
Paddington tick-tock and it don't stop
commander data Lieutenant Commander data
okay data he was in a movie I'm gonna
say the dude from the Big Lebowski the
dude all right
BAM we got our three we heard Joe first
with Paddington we heard Mike second
with data we heard Julia third with the
dude
20 seconds begin for Joe star whenever
he speaks you know sometimes instead of
force a leader needs to lead with a drop
of honey or dare I say a drop of
marmalade
I think Paddington Bear is a nice
combination of these two people he
respects order he respects discipline he
understands that things sort of need to
happen a certain way for this ship to
operate but he's also very sweet and
chill like the dude very kind to these
people they'll respect him you know he
turned a time all right Mike data
submarines these days are controlled by
mostly Bluetooth data is a computer he
can download exactly how to control a
submarine which is harder to drive than
a boat and he can he knows what to do
immediately he can interface he doesn't
even have to touch the controls he can
just think something and then it happens
folks he is a living computer he is like
a perfect AI he can take that boat
anywhere he knows how to use the thing
so submarines contrasting to ships that
are on the sea don't have to interact
with many other humans so there's
probably less stakes with you know there
being an attack so the dude is a perfect
person he's just going to have the best
life blissed-out smoking weed he's gonna
play you know whatever submarine Bowl
that he's going to create a bowling game
and he's just going to have his best
life and I want that for the right
10-second rebuttals joestar
a robot's instincts are not necessarily
going to match the instincts of a very
polite British bear in all situations
and you want your Paddington best this
bear turned around to jail and made
these people willing to die for this
bear to help him escape
Mike folks these are two characters with
a lot of goofs up goof ups we can't have
that at and when we're under sea water
data is a military man look he would
look great in the Navy outfit come on
let's be honest imagine it it's adorable
think about it it's beuter than
Paddington Paddington is naturally
curious so he's definitely going to open
that latch and he's gonna kill himself I
felt like a robot underwater is just a
disaster waiting to happen let's
consider any iPhone any iPhone let's
consider any iPhone even the new one all
right Wow three pretty different
captains here so we are going to pick
who does not move on to the speed round
and yeah I man these were three good
arguments a lot of fun but at the end of
the day Julia when you said that your
captain would be blissed-out smoking
weed that does not instill confidence in
me for the voyage ahead and yeah I mean
if I was on the if I was on the sub yeah
I'd want to hit him up for a little 420
action but interact with human so he
doesn't need to be professional oh there
there's a crew on the submarine oh I
forgot about that
okay sadly I have to say Julia Danielle
oh yeah this was all so sorry these were
great for with Mike's argument I was
really wishing someone would hammer back
on him about the idea of like just
running the sub by himself and not
actually having to deal with any of his
crew and yes you should not get robot
sweat I think although I feel like the
data's gotten wet before data gets wet
all the time
[Laughter]
did I phrasing I didn't mean it as much
as all these were great arguments I have
to agree with how just because Julia I
also want to watch him do under the seat
bowling but I don't know if that's
what's best for you know greedy just
reading the oceans yeah alright Stan did
you thought that for the record data is
an Android not a robot and he did get he
was submerged completely underwater in
Star Trek construction he was just fine
yeah they can go under will they do the
rice trick with them this is perfectly
capable of handling underwater listen
y'all tread lightly if you're coming at
Dan about Star Trek Terr jaws facts okay
Julia you brought it today you are
entertaining as hell and yeah sadly you
will not move on to this speed round but
I will maybe come to you for some
thoughts and opinions here right great
yes yes okay we're moving on to the
speed round it works just like the
tiebreak we just did and we will find
out who is going to take the day it's
won won the tiebreaker did not count for
points yeah oh we're far from the
shallows now to Lady gaga okay question
one of the speed round Joestar Mike
Carlson hmm what is the best movie fish
or sea creature
flounder the crocodile in Peter Pan croc
from pan flat we heard flounder first
from Joe 20 seconds begin whenever you
speak usually everyone's favorite
character in a movie is that cool
bestfriend character and that's flounder
he's just this the solid number 2 -
Ariel he's a great wingman he's there to
help he's never really there to hinder
is there to help her live her best life
she has some some great lines some funny
songs
he's a very adorable design so you've
got that going he turns into a great
plush and he's just also a great bounce
to Sebastian the croc is also a great
plush it's been flatter flounders like
the 10th best character in The Little
Mermaid the crocodile is the original
jaws people jaws wouldn't exist if it
weren't for this crocodile the crocodile
is the scariest part of the movie you're
late you're waiting for him to come back
he said taking literally a ticking clock
it is like the best of like a Chekhov's
gun of any movie he is so I think the
fear factor in the croc is taken away
from the fact that most of the time he's
like this he's always sort of smiling
happy in it it sort of takes the fear
away whereas flounders just this really
chill best friend you're like I want to
be a mermaid so I can hang out a
flounder the crocodile having a sense of
humor adds to it we don't want to see
some grim croc it makes him more
sinister that he likes to have fun and
he wants to eat Captain Hook flounder it
doesn't even sing a song he just like
rub that thing on his boy he gets rubbed
you know what I'm talking about the two
very different choices Dan Merle very
you're right two very different choices
I think I'm gonna give the edge to Mike
but just barely I think he knocked down
Jo about the the importance of flounder
he doesn't see there are other people in
the movie who hold Greater import
whereas the croc you know I think George
had to reframe it is a scary argument
Mike I thought fought well against that
I my votes gonna go with Mike you know
I'm also gonna go for Mike especially
because man when you reference check
offs gun when you use a theatrical
reference
the gun must be fired as it comes out it
must be fired the crime must eat I just
spoke to me I agree with you how I just
want to play which Peter Pan adaptation
are you referring to the Disney one okay
alright cuz there was a hook and there
was a modern Peter Pan and I just feel
like we we needed that the audience
needed that that's right so it is to one
mic let's go to question number 2 of the
speed round
what actor would give the best
performance as a shark via motion
capture yeah
best mocap shark hmm Bill Hader hmm
Wallace Shawn still hater Wallace Shawn
we heard hater first
Joestar I think mocap is sort of a
two-pronged attack you need a great
voice actor and you need a great
physical actor Bill Hader knocks it out
of the park with both of those he's he's
very serpentine and his movements just
like you need to be when you put on that
life little like suit that you have to
wear to do mocap also he can do a
variety of voices that are just gonna
nail it depending on what kind of shark
you need he can do scary shark he can do
friendly shark he can do drunk shark he
can do happy shark in Hindi sad shark
while Shawn plays the dinosaur in Toy
Story it's fantastic he is one of the
quirkiest if not the quirkiest character
actor of all time he's gonna bring
something unusual and animal-like to a
shark and he's gonna be a nice shark
sharks don't have to be mean once we
actually get to see and find their
personality we find that this is a very
nice shirt and wallet Shawn is so
endearing he's so wonderful he is so
lovable that he is going to bring the
most heart of the most heart and human
Bill Hader brings a level of endearing
this to all of his characters whether
it's Stefan or whether it's Barry and I
think he would really knock that out of
the park and you know while Shawn has
had his days he's done voices for a long
time this is the Bill Hader songs that
were in and Bill and Bill hate and were
losing endearing contests with Wallace
Shawn let's be very honest folks Wallace
Shawn is so much more endearing the
imagine him with a fin on his head
jawoll is drawn with a fin on his head
all right
from who
I gotta give it to Mike when it comes to
endearing but I gotta give it to Joe
when it comes to everything else Joe
star makes it for me Danielle Oh
both great arguments but I do we didn't
we didn't say exactly what kind of shark
it was gonna be there was a sendiri
versus endearing argument but ultimately
Joe had it for me when he said that it
like it is true Bill Hader can do a
variety of different kinds of sharks he
can give a bunch of different
performances as much as I love Wallace
Shawn did did too did to do definitely
he is Wallace Shawn and everything wears
no hater can be whatever kind of Chuck
we need it is a Bill Hader sense you
were right right Julia would you have
had a choice on this I would say Bill
Hader I mean I did an actor question oh
peter dinklage peter ding yeah I feel
like you would bring some gravitas to
the role right a sinister shark I'm
going to be a real basic and say Andy
Serkis okay here we go it is wow we are
locked up at 2:00 - how exciting
um if the creature from the shape of
water had dialogue what actor should
have provided the voice hmm the voice of
the creature of shape of water
Tom Bergeron Tom Bergeron the host of
Hollywood Squares right etcetera videos
okay my mom met him she says he's nice
mom's crushing on Tom B Bronson Pinchot
from perfect stranger present Balki also
in true romance Bronson Pinchot he's
done a lot of reality shows - on vh1 in
the 90s okay we heard Tom Bergeron first
Joestar
I think there was a mainstream barrier
of entry to the shape of water
especially for older audiences and I
think Tom Bergeron the greatest host in
television history is what fixes that
you give that weird fish the voice of
Tom Bergeron and all the sudden your mom
and your grandparents are like what's
this movie Tom Bergeron I love him with
Dancing with the Stars and they come in
and see it it becomes much more of a
box-office hit it solves a lot of
Academy problems with them being like oh
just movies that don't make any money
when it Kadim E Awards I think with
Bergeron you're getting something it
feels too familiar this is an animal
that lives somewhere close to us we want
to get the sense that it's from a
faraway place which is why bronson
pinchot doing his balki voice from
perfect strangers is the perfect choice
for this this is an accent this is
something that will make people feel
like all this though underwater is a
faraway place this is in America this is
another thing it will give another
dimension to the kick I think one of the
themes the shape of waters that were
more similar than we are different and
Tom Bergeron gives that feeling of
familiarity and similarity I can see why
she would fall in love with a fish man
with the voice of Tom Bergeron it's a
great voice it's a friendly voice it's
an inviting voice it's the balki voice
is fun and we want that character to be
fun we don't want him to be a boring dry
gameshow hosts we want that karahi's he
looks fun he needs to sound fun bronson
pinchot Balki voice all right Dan morose
that's I says Dan did not care for
either of these choices no I know it's
so many of my favorite movies today why
today oh yeah you know I think I know
one me over with the the argument that
is very didn't closest out of the movie
that we are more alike than we are
different and I felt like Jose picklists
and keeping in that spirit and Mike's
pick was in going with the differences
it was a very smart counter-argument
from Joe so I would go with Joe and Tom
Bergeron uh you know I I had kind of the
the flip of that Mike's argument spoke
most to me even though Joe's counter was
somewhat effective I thought just this
this fish was an outsider a stranger a
perfect stranger if you will in this
world and yeah I just as
as soon as he said the Balki voice I
heard it because I'm a child of the 80s
and I saw the show and know it so I'm
going Mike
Danielle I absolutely have to agree with
Dan that it was the theme argument for
me as well there are more things that
bring us together than tear us apart
Plus also I'm sorry like I don't want to
see Balki as cloaca all right Joestar
pulls into the lead it's three two this
is game point for mr. Joestar Mike you
need this one to keep her going
all right who's the best movie pirate
best movie pirate who is that Captain
Hook Captain Hook Disney Captain Hook
Thank You Great Joestar
[Music]
I'm gonna go up the Dread Pirate Roberts
Wesley mmm alright Dread Pirate Roberts
Wesley Mike you spoke first begin
whenever you're ready captain hook one
of the most iconic villains of all time
this is we've seen him in so many
different forms of media because the
character looms so large and everyone's
he is scary he is that sort of the
personification let me tell you sorry I
was a little kid I saw Peter Pan
Captain Hook was the scariest guy he was
this one I was afraid of the most this
speaks to how too scary and evil the
character is and how much he has in him
the Dread Pirate Roberts is not just one
guy it's a legacy character of God like
people pass the mantle that's how scary
that this pirate is is that it literally
crosses generations to generations
Wesley is also like a morally complex
guy he's scary he's a murder but he's
also in love you can't fault him for
that yeah he pirates he plunders but he
also up follows his heart he's a cool
sword fighter he Captain Hook makes a
great plush and he's also a great sword
fighter folks this is uh this is a
villain who has done first of all
accomplishments he has done so much for
the Dread Pirate Roberts he is actually
done he is a man of bad guys that Wesley
as Roberts became a scourge of the sea
and then he became a scourge of this
kingdom with some of the all-time
greatest monologues badass moments he
actually died and came back for the life
that's a pretty boss pirate he stole his
life back from death I'm alright Daniel
Radford this is really again amazing
argument today uh it's as much as I do
love plushies and we have referenced
them way more than I would have thought
very petty fight really you know the the
the arguments about Mike's argument
which was great about how many times
Captain Hook has shown up was easily
bested by Joe's argument about Deborah
Roberts being a legacy character and
then you had just dying and coming back
to life
and not only being a scourge of the sea
but her skirt to the land I got to go to
jail you know what for everything
Danielle said I concur Joestar you take
that
take the day Wow well he bought
everybody nicely done Joe star you just
won aqua aquatic movie fights what are
you gonna do next I am going to go to
Long Beach I'm gonna rent one of those
little little pontoon boats and you can
get a lot of people on for you know 50
bucks yeah and I'm gonna run over as
many fishing lines as I can Joe
well-fought everybody nicely done you
wanna give any shoutouts tell us where
we can find you
you guys know where you can find me I
just as usual want to give a shout out
to to these two legitimately two of the
funniest people I know and it's always
really fun to be able to do this show
and anything else with you guys so yeah
this is fun for sure Mike Carlson
awesome you pushed it to the limit here
thank you thoughts shoutouts shoutouts
to these two very funny people I would
also like I feel like a [ __ ]
plugging my own podcast after he just
plugged my abilities as a human being
but it's podcast or I'll do it anyway
it's about theme parks it's a podcast
and now we have a patreon so go to a
podcast to ride Twitter it's old fun
we'll have our wishes everybody was
gonna be on it we've had Julian on to
talk just the mall outside of Disneyland
Paris yeah yeah the type of specificity
you're gonna get and we also we just put
we put up a patreon episode just about
Botanica I have an email correspondence
with the creator William katsu and you
were a great piece of merchants your
merch store right now oh yes we created
a character on the episode called pot
Tana cush and he is like a 420 version
of Botanica s' and there's a shirt now
that I want to talk about gun town
Mountain in Bowling Green Kentucky good
tell mo that sounds great yeah it's
gonna be fun town Mountain and now we
don't know what its gonna oh my I once
took a hallucinogenic at a water park
Scots that was in college a Julie
Prescott all the things listen
everything's coming up Simpsons
we're on max fun the recent episodes
we've had Maurice LaMarche we had algae
known for his second episode talking
about the Garry Shandling show and we're
gonna have more Simpsons show runners
but then also comedians and creators and
all that good stuff and then also I made
a show called townies it's the OC in the
Old West so if you like horny teens but
you know I do based on this conversation
today you can go check out the horny
teens of the Old West it's on black
pills you can download it on your phone
all the first season John Ennis is in
and Natalie pelopidas whole bunch of
people yeah very funny people awesome
that sounds great thanks Julia
dan Moreau thank you for holding it down
and you know what I think I speak for
the entire Internet when seeing you get
a little bit mad at Joe's answers is
it's delightful it wasn't his answer al
it was how he fought it completely
disappointed and rural is a great flavor
Merle ever said that to me how the face
pumpkin guys Dan thank you for Jennifer
yeah just bringing that Danielle Radford
oh yeah as per huge find me on Twitter
I've got a patreon we do fun Tings dear
white why that accent that's how Kermit
the Frog was talking about
[Laughter]
yeah Danielle thank you so much and yeah
everybody everybody loves cracking up
and yell that's a good speed of Danielle
you guys thanks for that I think I
laughed the most in this episode yeah
this mission accomplished there and yeah
thank you thank you for watching movie
fights please hit me up on Twitter and
Instagram we'll talk stupid stuff and
we'll talk else has tag owl nation
Percival the owl what a nice little owl
fella Thank You Billy biz Thank You jte
and we'll see you next time bye-bye
[Music]